[Music]
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name may your kingdom
come
may your will be done
[Music]
father daniel i would like you to meet
father peter costello
father daniel comes highly recommended
as our newest and finest recruiter
what did the archbishop tell you about
me you're the best sex who says there is
what he didn't tell you was that they
can teach you the prayers but that's not
what separates us from your average
priest
you need to be willing to put yourself
at risk
change those clothes you look like a
priest
an exorcist doesn't hide from evil he
runs toward it
you know what i witnessed it's the
epitome of darkness
this young boy needs help i saw this on
the news this morning
he murdered his family so what are you
waiting for
i know you
other day you
are my dream
[Music]
that demon was the strongest i've ever
seen
evil is clever he needs an
army and an army needs soldiers
[Music]
so they can grow more and more powerful
never scored a cell
[Applause]
[Music]
well
[Music]
you